en attendant les vaccins pour tous les
aéroports resteront vides tant que les
risques de contagion dans les transports
aériens n'auront pas été entièrement
éliminé mais si vous empruntez une de
ces compagnies aériennes qui vole vers
paris vous n'aurez pas à subir de
quarantaine à l'arrivée une clinique de
dépistage rapide de l'aco vide est à la
disposition des voyageurs le passager
aura besoin de 30 minutes avant
l'embarquement seulement surtout si le
test a été réservé à l'avance avec le
laboratoire biron qu'il administre le
test coûte 149 dollars il est aussi
possible de présenter un texte
conventionnel pcr effectués dans les 72
heures précédentes
le prélèvement se fait de façon
visiblement moins désagréable que pour
un test pcr la réaction chimique se
produit à l'intérieur de cette tablette
est l'élu après 15 minutes par cette
machine négatif c'est ce qu'on veut un
passager positive sera pris en charge et
ses plans de voyage seront changés en
fonction de sa quarantaine
le test est il fiable dans notre méthode
est efficace à 90% toujours
comparativement à baissèrent pas de
quarantaine en france mais à son retour
au canada le passager devoir respecter
la quarantaine car le canada n'a pas
encore validé ces tests antigénique ici
on parle d'un projet pilote parce qu'on
va train c'est évidemment tout est
nouveau
le test en jean et qu'on l'attendait
depuis longtemps il disposait maintenant
l'idée c'est d'accumuler des données
pour premièrement est ce que c'est un
service qui plaît aux voyageurs à ce que
ces services qui est intéressant est est
ce que
les autres territoires finances que les
autres par les autres territoires à
l'international vont axer accepté cet
être à montréal on teste au départ à
calgary c'est à l'arrivée pour dispenser
les passagers internationaux de
quarantaine c'est un autre projet pilote
l'iata l'association des transports
aériens low asei l'organisation mondiale
de l'aviation civile ont élaboré des
procédures qui inclut ce genre de test
ou départ de préférence
il faut maintenant que tout le monde
s'entende pour les appliquer de la même
façon partout c'est de la ferme et de la
faire la bonne façon de faire de façon
les aéroports 100 ans
une mesure qui est efficace pour tous je
pense que la clé c'est vraiment bluffant
pratiquement la bonne façon et
efficacement le passager tester reçoit
une attestation sur papier
prochaine étape logique un carnet de
santé avec test et vaccins on travaille
sur des applications électroniques
jean michel leprince sera du canada
montréal